we had everybody at that protest and
that's what scared the beezers out of
the political class it was both of them
conservatives and liberals lock step
that put forward these lockdowns we
became the official opposition Not only
was it your personal but also your
business account so they were
effectively trying to make you go bus
the government was trying to make you go
bust we didn't do it you know for my
myself we did for all of us because we
got to put an end to clown world you
know how media works I wanted to deny
them the intellectual property of their
own content so they could smear us and
loop every day I was trying to show the
world you don't need Legacy Media that
alternative media platforms like this uh
have way more viability than Legacy
Media we learned about the Holocaust all
the time what did I learn in all those
years in school Bingo what I learned was
that was the
[Music]
government hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kissen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is one of the leaders of the
Canadian Freedom Convoy protest that we
saw last year which became a global news
story and he's WR a book about his
experiences called honking for Freedom
what a great title Benjamin dictor
welcome to trigonometry it's a pleasure
thank you for having me this is the book
look forward to talking to you about it
before we get into all of this and it
was such an interesting and massive
story at the time the way it was
covered that was interesting um but
before we do all of that tell us who are
you how are you where you are what's
been the journey that lead you to be
sitting here talking to us uh it's been
a long journey uh so my my name Benjamin
dictor I am a trucker in Canada or have
been for a few years I really got into
it during coid uh to escape uh what
Canada had become but I've been a Serial
entrepreneur I've been a diamond grader
I've been a corporate sales director ran
my own business on a University campus
for almost 10 years and I saw wokeism
enter the university space it really
started around 2012
2013 and and every year things would get
more and more extreme to the point that
after four years the students you
wouldn't recognize them they would leave
with this cynicism victimization
narrative hating the world and it just
got progressively worse and the faculty
as well so I ended up ultimately selling
that business and getting into
podcasting just I couldn't be in that
environment anymore so this entire shift
we've seen culturally is not new to me
and I guess that's what ultimately left
to me being the spokesperson for one of
the global uprisings against the shift
in The Narrative of our culture which I
think needs to stop and uh so here we
are so you see a link between wokeness
and what you experienced in Canada
during coid oh yeah 100% what's that
link because some people will say well
Justin Trudeau is just an authoritarian
or or everybody was scared or it was
about safety or
whatever but why do you say there's a
link so I'll qualify this by I I've also
Run for the conservative party in Ken in
the past so I know the behind the scenes
mechanism how everything works Justin
Trudeau is a symptom he's not the cause
and Justin Trudeau really H everybody on
Parliament Hill knows he doesn't make
any decisions he has no idea what's
going on the pmo runs the country so you
have these uh quiet you know these
secretive bureaucrats behind the scenes
that are running the entire wheel of the
country and they just sorry can I just
pause you there what does pmo mean oh
sorry prime minister's office okay so
the prime minister's office is running
the country and so they don't have any
scrutiny in the media he's just the
puppet that they run out to be they roll
out to be the punching bag he doesn't
read the new this is from a former
liberal Cabinet member who's told me
this he doesn't read the news he doesn't
know what's going on he the deal was
he's going to be the relationships
manager and he let that slip one time
when he first got elected so they run
the country they tell him Justin go out
and talk about these three four issues
and that's why he seems so in so in
congruent from what's actually going on
to what he what he's actually saying he
has no clue and and I think I would
argue we're seeing seeing an element of
that in the United States as well so
come back to me uh come back with me to
wokeness and the connection between that
and and what you guys were protesting
about okay so the wokeness is the
underlying philosophy of people like
Justin Trudeau and the people within pmo
so they're all very postmodern in their
worldview all subjectivists all the
negative aspects of postmodernism what
you see within that team and people who
were protesting and I think this is what
scared the government so much is those
are your middle class people and your
Working Class People and your small
business owners
I was shocked during this protest the
the range of people from various
demographics political and socieconomic
that I was dealing with everything from
workingclass truckers to billionaire
hedge fund managers to teachers to
people who worked in government to
police officers who privately would uh
communicate with me we had everybody at
that protest and that's what scared the
beers out of the political class sorry
Francis I I mean to interrogate I'm just
C very curious about the thing that you
said which is how does wokeness connect
to restrictions mandates Etc do you feel
that that that's what I'm getting do you
feel that there's a link there oh yeah
100% so tell me about that because I'm
curious what exactly you mean what is
the connection the connection is the
authoritarian nature of wokeness what
does wokeness do it restricts your
speech it restricts what you can say and
it restricts what you can think well
that's what we're seeing within our
governments as well and that's why we
protested I mean it's a great point I
guess my question is so when I was
growing up I used to look at Canada and
it seemed to me like America but not
mental the unamerican Americans yeah
yeah exactly you know and it was just
and I knew people went to live in Canada
it always kind of seemed like this kind
sort of Lefty Paradise a lefty Paradise
that worked and then
over Co I just saw them dis s send into
Insanity how has this happened because
obviously it didn't just happen with Co
there were things brewing for a while
well once again Justin troo is a symptom
so I think it's been in Rapid decline
for Generations example my dad was a
teacher so my dad was very
egalitarian and you know somewhere in
the center maybe fiscally conservative
because he came from a business
background and I remember one time if I
remember 1989 he came came home from
work and he was he would always talk to
us about work and what's going on and he
was very frustrated and he was
frustrated the fact that we had they had
a new policy at the Board of Education
you can only be hired to a senior
position as a teacher or in you know the
ministry or the board if you're a woman
now again my dad is very egalitarian
doesn't have a problem with women en
roles so I said to him well what's the
problem with that he said the problem is
they just have to be women they don't
have to be qualified so I walked into my
school this year and found out my uh my
secret our secretaries from last year
are now the principles and when I asked
them what are we going to do for the
budget they didn't understand that that
is their responsibility and they know
nothing about how to read a balance
sheet and this was in the late 80s that
you started to see this so this has been
my entire life you've seen a little bit
over over time you know in terms of
postmodern Theory look I'm no philosoph
y Professor but we all have our ideas if
you take it my historical view is you've
seen postmodernism encroach into the
Arts starting in the 60s it then got
into education at least in the Canada in
the 80s and 90s and now it's dominated
politics and that's part of the chaos
what's causing the chaos right now
because it's interesting that you say
that it went into education because I
could not believe for the life of me
that they reelected Trudeau after
everything he did I was I I genuinely
thought to myself who is voting for this
man well is this when I explain why the
conservatives
suck take the floor that's the moment
everyone switches off and this is why
everybody gets angry at me and there's
you know activists online that are
targeting me and trying to smear me
because I'm not going to engage in team
play we both there's no philosophy
that's always correct and the problem
with conservative politics there's two
things firstly they're weak they're
never going to challenge anything they
always seed ground to the other side and
the problem with that is if you're not
if you're going to promise conservative
policies but all you get is rhetoric
their base the next election around
decides you know what I'm I'm just not
voting for them again because they
didn't do what I wanted so that allows
the leftwing parties to go even further
to the left right so that's why we have
this Progressive uh fall off a cliff
from the political left but the other
problem is the unip party uh issue which
I was just on Lotus Eaters the other day
and we were discussing this very fact
that's happening in the UK as well it's
it's scary you can almost copy and paste
the UK political structure onto Canada
in the case of Canada we have our
conservative party Pierre PV who's the
new leader and the deputy leader of the
conservative party is a woke supremacist
who used to Target me and other people
we are very Pro gay pro you know people
we have a lot of friends in the gay
community and uh she was also a lobbyist
for a Lobby firm that was co-founded by
Justin Trio's chief of
staff and who was her last client her
last client was Walmart where she
lobbied for Walmart During coid to be
able to stay open and other businesses
small businesses should be shut down and
to reinforce the coid lockdowns and
what's really frustrating for all of us
involved in the trucker protest it was
both of them conservatives and liberals
lock step that put forward these
lockdowns you know in we we have a
federal systems we have Federal and
provincial parliaments which you guys
don't have what frustrates me is people
want to talk about Justin Chau how bad
he is and he is he's got to go there's
no question but guess what the passports
in my Province came from the Ontario
conservative party remember Rob Ford his
brother Doug Ford is the Premier and
he's the one who imposed the passports
and just before the trucker protest rein
reinstituted mask mandates and was
contemplating do we have should we have
passports for grocery stores Pharm and
pharmacies that was where conservatives
doing that so I'm not going to engage in
team play of oh team blue is good and
team bad is red no they all
suck I mean hard to argue with that it's
not yeah you've got yeah you can't argue
with that because that is unfortunately
the truth they might say and push back
on me on this go look hang on a second
right BJ most people wanted lockdowns
most people were demanding it sometimes
I felt that in this country that we were
a part of a select minority of people
who didn't want
lockdowns yeah it's interesting
I mean first thing when I discussed the
whole unip party scenario that also
applies to the lobby uh business that is
running these political parties you have
this thing what's a yugov where every
poll is
73% and I saw it in my old business my
old business was on a University campus
where we were often producing and
replicating thesises for professors that
were preparing these things for the
provincial govern government or the
municipal government and you know not
that you look through stuff but you're
you're going through it with the
professors or the students and trying to
format and they would talk about their
stuff they'd be in the store for two
three hours and they' tell us what
they're doing they'd show us their
reports and they'd show us their surveys
all of them were leading questions the
data is wrong this why like loves Scott
Adams so much we've gotten to know each
other a little bit because the data is
always wrong if you don't know the pr
presuppositions then you can't trust the
data so when people say 73% or you you
go 73% of people wanted lockdowns really
because in my life in the most in my
frame in the most Lefty part of Toronto
I couldn't say 73% wanted I know a lot
of people didn't know what to do and
wouldn't couldn't make a decision and
they want leadership in government to
make the decision because they have a
better overall view of what's going on I
think that's a better representation and
I think you can add to that as well that
those decisions and opinion polls
weren't done in a neutral environment if
the government keeps shoving fear porn
down your throat people are going to get
scared and we actually saw during the
pandemic that if you ask the average
person in the street uh what the death
rate from coid is they would generally
overestimate it by a factor of 100 at
least they' say it's 50% many of people
so if you think Co has a 50% death rate
yeah locking people in the home starts
to look a bit more reasonable at that
point I'm not saying it is reasonable
but but that's we didn't do this during
SARS remember Toronto was particularly
hit during the SARS outbreak and what
was the death rate of SARS was 34% we
didn't do any of these measures during
SARS yeah you wash your hands we didn't
even have masks it was just you know use
uh hand cleaner hand sanitizer careful
who you talk to you know just don't they
didn't even do the social distancing
none of that and you know what we got
out of that that was a 34% death rate
I'm guessing it's probably to something
to do with the contagiousness of it
right didn't maybe because it was so
deadly didn't spread as much but anyway
and the other thing is sorry I mean to
cut you off very look we were all scared
yeah I'm vaccinated as well I waited as
long as I could I had no choice
cuck I knew say that it's just I'm just
joking it's not a joke it's the facts
and uh you
know this is what people say to you to
to vaccinate people online you're a CU
for getting and what happened to it's
your decision you do what you want well
exactly that and that was the whole
tenor of the freedom Convoy is freedom
you get to choose my body my choice
right and um Scott's going to yell at me
for saying that but anyways the I
remember in the first couple of weeks
everybody's starting trying to explore
what's going on this doesn't sound right
it's so different than than SARS the
behavior is not what we've seen and we
also have certain people in government
that we know may have some ulterior
motives uh political entryism is a
problem in Canada particularly from
people you know and organ organizations
NOS uh from outside of Canada and I
remember I had a You know despite the
fact that I'm a little bit of a Rabel
Rouser I have people who are supportive
and try to get me information who are
elected officials in both in many
parties not just the conservative party
who feel the same way as us and one of
them told me in a private conversation a
couple weeks in they said I don't
understand why we're doing any of this
just between you and I none of this
makes sense we've spoken this is the
conservatives we've spoken to Doug the
leader he won't listen to any of us the
senior health officials are completely
incompetent they're trying to cover for
themselves said don't believe any of
what you're saying this is all nonsense
and he said to me you know how our
parties work I'm like yeah yeah I know
how the parties work so once I heard
that uh then I realized okay let's let's
be a little bit more let's step back a
little bit and maybe it's not quite as
bad as we think and that was uh in my
opinion that was the case this became an
opportunity for governments that uh for
changes in public policy
in my city particularly like for example
local issues they want to put bicycle
Lanes on every Street in the city of
Toronto because you know when it's minus
20 degrees everybody wants to ride bicy
right and they did it you can't same in
London you can't drive in the city
anymore same in London bus lanes used to
be only during certain hours now they're
permanent and so you've got a traffic
jam in one lane and an empty bus lane
247 B bicycle L everywhere listen we've
talked a lot about the background which
everybody a perspective on where you
were coming from when you decided to get
involved and actually do something how
did the protest start how who formed it
why you know what was the central theme
of it uh just give us the background to
how the actual Freedom Convoy began okay
so well now that we know a lot more
since the Convoy a lot has come out
since the poec commission and diverg
media I encourage everybody to check out
diver media uh independent journalists
have been digging into some of the
evidence that was provided uh what I
learned in writing my book was there was
a team of 11 ended up being 11 truckers
started with Bridget Belton and a couple
of others communicating over Tik Tok and
saying we need to have a CO a convoy
because they're already starting to have
problems at the border uh she had one
particular issue she was basically
harassed by cbsa our border control and
she got online and started saying we
have to have a convoy other people in
the trucking industry were getting very
frustrated as well they saw their
livelihoods were about to evaporate
because they could no longer cross the
border and they just found each other
online and decided okay we're going to
do a convoy they initially wanted to do
what's called slow rolls you have a
convoy trucks driving slowly just you
know causes disruptions to get attention
from the government and then some people
with political ties got involved and I
think ultimately co-opted it but in
diverge media's documentary that's
coming out soon will explain a lot of
that uh but I was eventually contacted
by people who I knew one was Tamara
leech uh to ask to be the spokesperson
and to do well to do media spokesperson
press releases all that sort of stuff
and I remember I've said this many times
that she in the very first call when she
she called me out of the blue I haven't
spoken to her in like a month or maybe
six weeks she said Hey listen uh my
friends and I or a bunch of us have
started a convoy and she said I love
these truckers and all but I I can't
have any of them uh go in front of them
media because we all know the media
traps right and she knew I was media
trained in the past I produ a bunch of P
podcasts not on record Steph hicks's
podcast whatever so she knew I was
comfortable in this domain and she said
would you be willing to be the
spokesperson and I said yeah sure i' I
agree with the cause I'm getting
frustrated as well and then I said to
her by the way did you know I have a
truck and she said no get out what do
you mean said well during coid uh I got
my license just before cuz my brother
suggested it and uh well I we saw
everything being locked down and I we
needed a taste of freedom and so we both
bought trucks and started going cross
border when I wasn't producing podcasts
working on other stuff became an owner
operator and uh went to the us to have a
little taste of freedom to get to know
my by the way biological brother who I
only met a few years prior so that's
what uh that's what I did during Co
that's very interesting so you got the
truck and then you became a spokesman
for the for the truckers the thing that
I found horrifying but almost
depressingly predictable was how quickly
the r racist racist R that's racist it
is mate racist prejudice against people
who like chist which yeah exactly is a
specific demographic but racist white
supremacist and that was just just
smeared against all these people and I
found that so depressing I found it
amazing they did exactly what I thought
they would do and what I wanted them to
do so in the early stages the Legacy
Media wasn't really talking about us
they were trying to ignore it so I
thought firstly I was when they were
starting to post a bunch of stuff of us
being Nazis cartoons here and there very
slight and I started make putting
statements online that the Toronto Star
the glob and mail uh CBC you're now
banned from our press conferences I I
made a point to ban them for a couple of
reasons because I've been in media
scrums before I know how they operate
what they're going to do is they're
going to come into a space like this
this is much larger than the space that
we had for our press conferences they're
comeing with a massive camera and a crew
of three people that take up half the
space they'll call us names when there's
a Q&A and then guess what they won't get
any views where's the upside there's no
upside in that and then the other thing
that some of the people there didn't
understand what I was trying to do I
wanted to deny them the intellectual
property you know how media works I
property of their own content so they
could smear us and loop every day like
they did during January 6th and Angelo
from the post-millennial laughed he told
me we did a podcast together he said
yeah the Legacy Media CBC CTV whatever
they had to log on to the
post-millennials feed to get content
what's going on in in uh in Ottawa and
what I was trying to do is a couple
things I was trying to show the world
you don't need Legacy Media that
alternative media platforms like this uh
have way more viability than Legacy
Media and um I I think it worked and the
other thing is I I was going for 100
million views the first week I thought
if I could capture amongst all of those
platforms 100 million views I will dwarf
all of Legacy Media and then they'll
have no choice especially since the vibe
and the framing that I was trying to
build around it so when Tamara called me
said you know let's think think about a
way to you know you present this she's
going to be on the road with them
crossing the country and what I
hearkened back to this is when they call
me leftwing pico uh when I was a
teenager going to Grateful Dead concerts
and fish concerts and Almond Brothers
that sort of vibe where you had all
people from demographic different de
demographics coming together around
music and just focusing on peace and
love and all that sort and that's what I
thought you know that's what we need we
need to have Woodstock right in front of
Parliament Hill and I think that's what
we ended up having and when did you know
that this was going big that this was
starting to become not only a national
story but an international
one this the specific moment I remember
one of the things that had a dramatic
impact you saw you know line go up with
analytics uh I was putting a bunch of
messaging out and I was I called every
contact that I had uh because there's
some you know very influential people
who I know who I never ask for any
favors or just friends and this was the
one time I tried to reach out to
everybody just to add to collect on a
favor do me a favor can you talk about
this
whatever and one of the first people I
reached out to was Gad sad to do an
interview with him and to talk about it
and whatever
and I remember one day early on in
January before we left or when when the
trucks were on the road I remember the
exact day one of the podcasts that I
produce I put a tweet out after talking
to Chris Gara who was on the ground he
was the first person working with the
Ottawa Police who were telling us where
to park the trucks very
important and uh he said our server
crashed we got up to 30 36,000 trucks
register ised he said uh we're now
estimating like 50,000 trucks maybe
we're trying to to get all the data and
they're struggling with it and we may
have up to half a million people coming
uh this weekend so I put out on a tweet
on one of my platforms uh well Justin
truro's gonna have a difficult week
50,000 trucks and a half a million uh
people and Jordan tweet Jordan Peterson
retweeted it did us the favor and then
when that happened Boom everybody
started to jump on and but only within
the alternative uh Legacy Media Framing
and the other problem is which I
explained the strategy in the book is I
couldn't do a freedom Convoy Twitter
account or a freedom Convoy Facebook
account because I was dealing with
censorship right that was right in the
heart of massive censorship so what can
we do all right we I guess we can use
hashtags and we'll use different
hashtags and change them up periodically
so it'll be all that much more difficult
uh to censor and I think it worked so I
ended up managing you know a bunch of
different Twitter accounts from
platforms that I have but myself and
Tamara leech's personal account both was
me and it was going great it was you
know there was I was following it and I
was really really invigorated by what
you were doing it just made me so happy
that there was push back that it was
done peacefully that it was done in the
right way and it wasn't partisan and it
wasn't partisan and it was great and
that made me so happy awesome and then
and then this is Francis when when when
when he gets happy when he gets happy
there's he always goes down going to go
off for Cliff now no he never it never
ends on the highway no it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't then just stand there
okay next
question it was so great but then it got
really bad and then that made me happy
no it doesn't but and then things
started to happen so tell us what
happened at that point when you started
to feel the chilly icy hand of
authoritarianism on your shoulder well
before that happened uh look explain how
politics works I think this is just
common knowledge there was a movement of
over half a million people who joined a
Facebook group we were raising record
money and just to give you some
framework in Canada it took uh the
Liberals 40 M 4 years to raise $40
million to get Justin Trudeau elected we
raised $23 million in 3 weeks
cumulatively wow yeah so holy that
that's crazy man are we talking about
the fact that Justin Trudeau got 40 no
no two two Jew two two Jews talking
about money man that's why we're excited
just let us have a let us enjoy our
moment so so you 23 million million see
I can't even say it yeah $23 million in
3 weeks in 3 weeks so those those
weren't dollars those were votes yes
because remember I discussed the uni
party we became the official opposition
so what is the political class going to
do and we saw that in the poac testimony
when the interm leader of the
conservatives after the previous idiot
resigned and Justin Trudeau were
emailing and talking to each other how
they need to end the protest right they
needed to prevent
I I guess what Their Fear was you see
this group of a half a million people
who are maybe largely but not
exclusively conservative or Freedom
minded raising record amounts of money
they can only dream of they need to put
an end to it Benjamin can I just stop
you there and I I want to come back to
this because what we're talking about is
super important and France's question is
really important there's something you
said there that bugs me so much in the
way which is it's not you it's the way
we talk is freedom has has become a
conservative issue do you not find that
incredibly weird it's frustrating
because when you I don't know if we're
the same age but I think we're close
when I was growing up Freedom was
definitely not a conservative issue
listen it was the conservatives that
wanted to shut down your freedom it was
the conservatives who wanted to ban my
video games wanted to ban my music they
wanted to ban anything I liked because
of you know religious purit reasons
right whereas during the Convoy I'm
talking to pastors who are talking to me
about yeah we have to be you know
freedom and you know the're very okay
they don't agree with me on certain LGBT
issues whatever okay fine but that
they're at least willing to listen and
have the conversation and focus on more
important issues right like they've
evolved uh you know it's people like
Justin Trudeau and the rhetoric from the
extreme left that have brought myself
and religious social conservatives
together and there's a lot of people
that like somebody I become close with
during this period uh is Megan Murphy
Megan used to be what she would identify
as a third W feminist socialist whatever
she's been on on trigonometry we're big
big fans she wonder she's wonderful
great person as well and so so now you
know five years ago we wouldn't have
been able to talk to each other now we
become friends and we're trying to find
common ground to help everybody else you
know so yeah it's it's really
frustrating we'll be back to our
interview with Benjamin in a second but
first we wanted to take a minute to tell
you about gien go giv s Go played an
integral part in the trucker story
helping them to stand up against an
authoritarian government oppressive
Banks and a funding platform that
abandoned them if you don't know about
gien go it's a crowdfunding platform
that allows people to raise money online
gien go can be used to raise money for
medical purposes business venture
personal needs and all sorts of other
causes that people have give Seno
support freedom of speech they don't
cave to the Mob and that's why we're a
proud partner with them go to gend
go.com and support people who support
freedom but anyway so come back to both
the parties are talking about how to
shut you guys down so they both saw that
we had this massive Facebook group we're
we're building our own database because
you know they always they only look at
life through political goggles and they
needed to shut it down so I I I knew
something was up and me and a few other
people realized there's something up
where we didn't know who what how it
what specifically how it was operating
but we saw there was something happening
and it was essentially people that were
aligned with the conservative party
infrastructure or should sorry the uni
party infrastructure that were trying to
do their best to co-opt it they wanted
to make it just about like they're
arguing with me they came in one by one
screaming at me and yelling at me I'm
like I got three interviews to do and I
had a little bit of a media team under
me there were five of us working on it
like I don't want to hear the political
nonsense
uh go do your thing and I I remember
before a GB news interview was exactly
that conversation uh they wanted to make
everything about vaccines for example it
has to be about the vaccines and the
data and whatever what do we discuss
about data you can't trust it right uh I
said we need Canadians together we need
the world to come together which means
we need people who we disagree with on
many issues to come together on the
right for free speech the right to of
free assembly and to protest and to talk
to each other but if you want to turn
devolve this into your little you know
uh vac antivaccine program you know
what's going to happen that's going to
kill the all the positive sentiment
we're getting from people who disagree
and you that the I think it was the
previous night that I had that
conversation I was in a Twitter space I
tried to do them when I could but I was
it was Bonkers every day and this
particular person was a school was a
former school trustee from a party we
call the NDP which is very very
left-wing and I don't know if there's
anything we would agree on uh
policy-wise but we had a wonderful
conversation about the the importance of
listening to each other and talking to
people we disagree with and freedom and
she's I'm I'm vaccinated but you should
have the right my body my choice you
should have the right to make choices
for yourself and even they started to
realize things are going a little bit
far but the unip party political
apparatus uh was doing the best their
best they could every minute to to tear
it apart from the inside so all aside
from all the other garbage we were
dealing with which was uh we needed to
get fuel to the truckers or they're
going to freeze some of them have their
kids in there oh they blocked the fuel
truck now okay I guess we'll have to get
Jerry cans oh they're seizing Jerry cans
now great oh some people are running out
of food oh we have a thousand trucks in
a farmer field we need to put them
somewhere like it was to St issues when
you use the word they what do you mean
by that who would they be J uh the
people that were trying to um uh the
political class that were doing their
best to try to capture the the freedom
Convoy and turn it into a voting block
okay does that make sense I see oh I see
so just to clarify I think you you you
picked it up in exactly the right place
for anwers there were it sounds like
there were two things happening many
there 50 things Happ 50 things happening
but in terms of the broad movement on
the one hand you had Justin Trudeau and
his government trying to shut you guys
down and we'll talk about Deb Banking
and and you know police Etc in a second
but also I think what I'm hearing you
say is there were people who wanted to
capture this protest against mandates
and all of this and to turn it into a
strictly one-sided party political
engine to drive their vote where they
wanted it to go they wanted to capture
this for the conservative cause
basically is that fair right that's
right okay and when they saw a guy who
is acting as a spokesperson who all of a
sudden he's saying we all suck then I
became the devil in the eyes of
conservative partisan politics and You
Know Tamar and I had that conversation
when she first called called me because
there was a 2019 Convoy for oil and gas
that was also co-opted that she got
involved with and I said we're not doing
this no politicians this is not for
political parties Tamara like I'll do it
as long as you agree to this that we are
there to end mandates and to end the
arrive can nothing more nothing less and
we're staying and she and she said she
agreed I said and we're staying there
until we get something from the
government right she agreed so yeah it
wasn't okay so all of this stuff is
going on but quite quickly I mean I I
remember seeing it wasn't maybe as bad
as Australia but I do remember scenes of
violence mhm people being attacked and I
also the thing that I think oddly I mean
we're so used to violence now for some
reason the thing that really shocked the
world was when people had their bank
accounts taken away and I saw this not
only through on the media we have fans
of the show we do these monthly calls
with our top supporters and one of them
is in Canada and she was saying I sent
money to the truckers I'm and she's a
pensioner living alone she say I'm I'm
terrified I don't know what will happen
to me if I don't have any money right so
this is this is where it quickly went to
yeah isn't it uh yeah it did so first
they when they did the emergency
measures act so I try to explain to my
American supporters that is can is
equivalent of Martial law the political
nerds will say no it's not different no
that's basically what it was right uh
they froze mine and the bank accounts of
several other people there two or 3
hundred people that had their accounts
Frozen it's not just your bank account
it's your bank account your credit cards
your lines of credit your corporate
accounts corporate lines of credit
everything you have to transact was
frozen and when I logged onto my bank
account I saw this message that when you
begin to transact your transaction or
when you begin to use your account your
transactions will appear here the one
Saving Grace that I had was I'm a
bitcoiner and I've been a bitcoiner
since you know many many years and
during the the
protest the the bitcoiners were raising
lot they ended up raising something like
$1.2 million for us and or 21 Bitcoin I
think is what it was and so they they
originally tried to contact the the
protest through Tamera uh they got
nothing but resistance and they were not
going to support the con
and then somebody saw me on one of the
news programs or an interview somewhere
or a podcast whatever it was and they
looked me up on Twitter sorry X Elon
it's X and uh they saw hash Bitcoin so
they started sending me DMS and you
could see they were testing me they're
like you're a bitcoiner I'm like yeah
how long youve been in Bitcoin what do
you know what wallet you use blah all
that sort of stuff so they realized okay
I'm the real deal and they said this was
kibou by the way big he uh Caribou is
the one who distributed all the the uh
Bitcoin to the truckers and was raided
by the police which is another issue but
um we they ended up raising $1.2 million
they came to me the next day and said
we're raising Bitcoin I said great uh I
I got your back uh we'll get it to the
truckers I went to the board of which
some of them were you know conservative
party Loyalists and I said we got a bit
bunch of bitcoiners raising money for us
the response I got was well that's for
criminal money and I'm like okay fine
forget it and so I just kind of helped
them and thank God because Bitcoin was
the only money that got through to the
truckers it's the only money that was
directly distributed and I tell that
story in the book so this what happened
to all the money that you raised because
one of the platforms you raised it on
that was I can't remember if they
prevent or if the government forced them
to not give you the money what happened
there uh it's really interesting because
ACC according to the treasurer it's
neither but uh that's that's his account
what happened first we had GoFundMe and
GoFundMe uh raised 10 something million
dollar $10.1
million and uh frustratingly that money
was transferred into Tamara's
account uh and she didn't return their
her phone call their phone call for six
days I don't understand that that
doesn't make sense to me uh because you
can't transfer stuff for an for a
nonprofit into a personal account so
okay fine we that we'll we'll figure out
over time and there's some investigative
journalist diverg media that's looking
into that but uh on February 5th and
there's a series of events that happen
and this is what I was dealing with
behind the scenes so the mood and
behavior was peace love unity and
freedom and then I explain in the book
where all of a sudden on February 5th uh
the lawyer one of the lawyers came in
and just decided to upload a video to
Twitter to say you know your freedoms
are under uh your freedoms are being
eroded Justin tro is tyrannical he's
destroying the country you're not going
to have a future left come down here and
um and come down down here support the
truckers and whatever and I lost my mind
uh that's not Freedom peace love and
unity and freedom that's not the mood
and behavior we were trying to build but
it's because a series of events already
happened on February 3rd the
conservative party leader who everybody
wanted to get rid of he resigned the
next day Candace Bergen the inter the
new interm leader of the conservatives
tried to bait us into uh joining her for
a a press conference and uh she wanted
to do meet us at thew to do uh I don't
know whatever it was she wanted to do a
photo op with the truckers uh everybody
else I I'm the one who I was this stiner
in the room I said no absolutely not
she's going to bait us and she's going
to tell us we all have to go home and
then we'll have zero political C capital
and it'll be over and I was right she
came out of Parliament that night
instead in a late session of Parliament
and she said the conservative part is
here for working working people truckers
blah blah blah and it's time while the
truckers go home and there were some
people in my room I said ha you see I
told you what would happen if we were
there so clearly I I could see right at
that point they were not in our favor
and then the next day the lawyers show
up do the video I go into uh I Storm
Into The Ark hotel where they all have
like a meeting room this is before I
broke my ankle about an hour before and
um I said what are you doing I used a
few expletives and was quite aggressive
for the first time everybody was shocked
that I could get so angry and uh he
responds with oh okay I'm sorry here you
have a $5 million lawsuit now a class
action lawsuit which has now swelled to
$450 million in damaging damages that a
few small businesses with ties of the
Liberal Party are dragging us through
the court system ongoing right now that
we're dealing with so clearly there was
way more collusion going on behind the
scenes than we realized both parties
wanted us out of there as quickly as
possible which we understand but we just
wanted to talk to somebody in the
government and they also were going
behind our backs which I didn't know uh
to meet with the city of Ottawa to
condense the the protest and they
brought this to me and said we're going
to go meet with the Ottawa the city of
Ottawa and work at a deal like excuse me
they told us where the park the city of
Ottawa and the Ottawa Police gave us our
parking spots we haven't spoken with
blackface yet right and I was actually
trying to we know who runs the party so
I know the people I know the procedures
I know how they would have talked to us
and I tried to tell them these are
people in government my dad had an
entire career in government everybody's
going to be poting the finger at each
other trying to defer blame to somebody
else or another department they'll do
that for a week and then at some point
they'll figure out who to talk to but if
you go to meet with them now and start
to acques to demands nobody has made
what you've never you're a lawyer you've
never negotiated before like what's
wrong with you people it's because they
were trying to end the the protest it's
you know listening to this story it's on
the one hand it's really inspiring
it's a classical you know the little guy
stands up against tyrannical oppressive
regimes on the other hand It's really
dispiriting because it's not just you
against government it's you against the
entire political class and the fact that
the bank your bank accounts were frozen
and you said Not only was it your
personal but also your business account
so they were effectively trying to put
trying to make you go bus the government
was trying to make you go robust and you
know what's interesting on that topic uh
what I did was I sent a an email to the
presidents of the two banks that I I
work with saying hey my name is Benjamin
why do you have my bank account Frozen
just out of curiosity CC a bunch of
lawyers yeah and uh which is one of the
podcasts I produced not on record and uh
I finally got a response in March so
after the protest was done after I tried
to avoid arrest which was a whole crazy
week which is another issue and um I got
a response and the response uh this
response letter I held on to it I held
on to it because I knew there was going
to be some sort of parliamentary
investigation into the bank account
freezing because the first lesson you
learn in politics everybody cares about
their money especially those who say
they don't they teach everybody that in
politics and Christa fredin who is
somehow somehow both the fin Min
Minister and the Deputy Prime Minister
at the same time never heard of that
before but whatever and on the board The
Advisory Board of the WF the world
economic Forum uh she was in this
parliamentary session trying to evade
questions and she let it slip to to
suggest that the bank accounts and
financial institutions took it on their
own accord to freeze bank accounts like
really really because I have an email
that says the opposite so I have a very
large substack I reached out to a
journalist uh a very experienced
journalist I know Mark Patron and said
hey Mark check out this email that I
haven't told anybody about and Christa
fredland he's like oh that's great do
you want to write an article about it so
he did uh Zero Hedge picked it up and I
guess effectively nuked that line of
narrative that the government was trying
to perpetuate that it was the the
financial institutions and what people
didn't understand what I was trying to
explain to people was you know this is
Maybe
not to like side with banks but is this
the the
inevitability of the excessive
overregulation of banks um that they
always complain about is this is where
we're going to converge that the
government can now in a very fascistic
manner dictate who gets a bank account
and who doesn't which is why hash
Bitcoin and what was really interesting
about the case is the first time that
I'd ever heard about Deb banking bank
accounts being Frozen and now we're
seeing it happen more and more in Brazil
it happened two months later yeah they
had a trucker protest after the
elections and what's the first thing
they did they froze all the bank
accounts of the truckers so do you think
this is something that we're going to
see happening we saw it with Nigel
farage in this country that's right
Nigel as well had the same we've had one
of our accounts suspended we're still
investigating what happened there as
well listen irrespective whether you
agree or not politically before the
Convoy what happened to Abramovich here
they froze every all his assets in the
United Kingdom and essentially stole his
his soccer team so and I think that's
why we had people from all demographics
reaching out to us because they realize
this is not a rich or poor issue this is
not a blue versus red issue this is the
political class who've gotten a little
bit drunk with power versus everybody
else who just wants to get on with their
lives
and the thing that I find really
worrying is that for me is foreshadowing
a world that we're going to be going
into where cash is going to become
obsolete that's my little conspiracy
theory that they use coid as a way to
eliminate cash MH cash is going to
become Obsolete and this is going to be
the way of controlling the
populace I you know yes uh yes and no
like I'm of two minds about this which
is by the way a skill I think we all
have to start developing is going back
to where we can simultaneously hold two
World beliefs people have forgotten that
I um I comment a lot of this because I
go in a lot of Bitcoin spaces I'm going
to be speaking in El Salvador and
Florida on bitcoin stages and stuff I
don't know that we're going to get a
cbdc uh that's what everybody's
concerned with Central Bank digital
currency because that's what that that
would allow the political class to do uh
I think what people misread about how
the political class behaves cuz I've
seen I've interacted with a lot of these
people uh some of the wealthiest people
in the world and we get this impression
that they are these authoritarian
controlling Hawks and there's no
question uh some people on I would call
it the authoritarian left have that sort
of vision but not all wealthy
billionaire influential industrial
people they're not a group they all have
different competing interests and many
of the people I that I've met within
that demographic they're just
scared fear is what's driving so much of
this and I think when we understand that
it's fear not the um this overl inflated
sense of control that some midlevel you
know political bureaucrat thinks they
have but the really top people they're
worried about this collapsing as much as
we are Elon Musk is a good example of
that whether you agree with him or not I
happen to but he's a good example it's
not he's not an authoritarian looking
for control uh it's Fear of Everything
collapsing so I think because of that
and because of the weakness of uh
politicians that politicians are always
looking for for one one thing very very
uh uh vigorously which is plausible
deniability and a cbdc pulls away the
curtain of everybody including
politicians who will have a cbdc and if
it's centralized I can promise you the
world's hackers will start doing their
best to hack centralized wallets of
politicians to see where all their money
comes from and that's once once they get
a win that all right it's over and where
it goes you're going to find some very
interesting things on both ends of so it
exposes them as as much as the rest of
us so I'm actually quite positive on and
this is also I advocate for Bitcoin and
then many the bitcoiners will say well
we're going to have exclusively Bitcoin
no I think we're going to have a Fiat
system that works with Bitcoin this new
asset this protocol that never existed
before and I think things are going to
work out uh it's just going to be some
bumpy roads for the next few years sorry
to be too optimistic no that's great
it's great France is disappointed yeah
why AR you telling me that I'm gonna
have no free but you know what's really
interesting talking to you cuz you know
your your family lineage to Venezuela uh
and we discussed this prior you know my
experience in Latin America you I'm sure
you're getting the same feeling that my
friends who live in Canada now are
telling me we're living in karacas in
2002 I'm sure you have those same sort
of sentiments as well don't you there's
there were times during coid where I
could feel almost like a PTSD response
to what is happening and also as well
not the thing that I found even more
worrying wasn't what the government were
doing it was looking around and people
who I thought were sane and rational and
reasonable behaving in a m in a manner
that was quite clearly irrational all
right it was just one day and I was very
upset you know but you know it was
really really disappointing you know
during firstly the political stuff in
the Convoy I want to make this clear
yeah not all the political attempts to
co-opt and Destroy from the inside
that's to be expected just didn't know
where it was coming from and how it was
working none of that takes away from
this beautiful moment where we all came
together you know the second interview I
did when I was there it was with a
journalist working for a French
publication she's she's from Quebec but
we did an hourong publication she
translated into French for it to go out
here and I asked her I always ask people
after the interview interviews and I'll
do the same with you what do you guys
think and I asked her what do you think
about what I just discussed in our
conversation and what's going going on
and she said to me you know my whole
life I've been a Quebec
separatist until I saw the trucks
driving across the country and that
everybody's starting to unify and
support each other despite our
differences she said I bought my first
Canadian flag ever and I now consider
myself Canadian that's the type of power
that we achieved with all of this so all
the noise and the nonsense I tell people
in my live stream
that's just the noise turn it on and off
and engage when you want to and focus on
on your life and I think we all start to
do that and we we resist the regular
dopamine hits of the negativity of
social media at least regulated I think
we're going to be a lot better off no I
couldn't agree with you more and it's
increasingly how I feel about everything
as well we'll be back with Benjamin in a
minute but first we wanted to tell you
about our friends at e DNS easy DNS is a
domain name register and host they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture
deplatform attacks or overzealous
government agencies move your domains
and websites over to easy DNS right now
all you have to do is go to easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com triggered use our promo code
which is triggered to get 50% off your
first
purchase
one of the things I wanted to ask you
very much along those lines is what were
the key objectives of the Convoy and do
you feel that the impact ultimately was
positive and and what are some of the
downstream effects what have we seen I
know you've had all sorts of
Investigations into aspects of this
going on in Canada so you know are you
happy with what was achieved what what
are some of the takeaways Etc yeah I'm
happy with what was achieved I'm not
happy in the way it was achieve so the
first thing is we look we were there for
two reasons despite what the fake news
wants to tell people we were there to
end mandates and we were there to end
the arrive can app which is the the data
tracking app that Canadians would have
to have on their phone to re-enter the
country right okay so that's what you're
there for and you could see in the first
week I mean it's a good thing I had
experience with politics and I'd been in
run campaigns and stuff I could see them
message testing on the provincial level
in the first week you see that a lot
when a politician will say one thing and
say the opposite the next day they're
just testing messaging to see how people
are responding and I think it was a five
days into it six days into it uh the
Ontario Premier Doug Ford who I
mentioned who is the one by the way who
sought the injunction of the $9 million
that was in GI and go that wasn't Justin
Trudeau that was the conservatives again
it's not red versus blue but you could
see he was testing messages suggested we
should take weend mask mandates and all
that sort of stuff once I saw that I
knew all right we're going to win we're
going to get rid of the man mandates
it's just going to take some time uh the
ones that held on the longest were the
extremists which were Justin Trudeau
Omar alabra and uh the pmo and they took
if I remember correctly was it 6 months
seven months something like that to
finally lift mandates for travel uh
within Canada so and you know they we
know how politics Works they have to
they have to do it but they have to have
plausible deniability which I was ready
for if Justin Trudeau had any sense of
wisdom he would have sat down with us
because I had an out for him and a home
run that everybody would look good
because all I wanted to do was have what
the United Kingdom had and what England
had right you guys started opening up
and dropping all your mandates and I
said that in our first press conference
we just want to go the direction of the
United Kingdom why are we holding on to
this sort of thing um but anyways uh you
know he doesn't definitely doesn't have
the strength of his father who is not a
fan of but there's no question his
father would have been out there to talk
to us and say okay what do you guys want
right and sort of thing so I'm happy
with that uh we achieved that particular
goal there were convoys in 30 plus
countries around the world that uh had
the same
frustration and uh the Dutch Farmers
Jordan pet was telling me in a private
conversation about this that they were
looking at what was happening in Canada
they're looking at kind of the weak
points that the government or the
authorities were able to exploit and
they adjusted their protest accordingly
and what happened they ended up forming
a political party they got 20% of the
vote in Parliament and now they can
block all the ridiculous nonsense that
may or may not come from the world
economic Forum right which is what the
political class colluded to prevent us
from doing what was very frustrating was
we had a public order emergency
commission is what it's called that was
the commission to investigate all the
circumstances around the freedom Convoy
and you could tell it was all I he's
rigged but there was definitely some
sort of setup behind the scene
negotiating deals same sort of thing as
we saw you know those emails uh where
there were two narratives going into
this I didn't have standing was denied
standing and if I had standing I would
have cross-examined people on both sides
which is I guess why they didn't want me
to have standing right but there are two
narratives going into the public order
emergency commission one was the liberal
narrative that it was ma it was Mad Max
pandemonium in the streets dead bodies
flying around whatever uh which
obviously wasn't true and then there was
the conservative side narrative which
was oh it was peaceful but it got out of
hand both of those things were not true
it was peaceful they got out of their
leader they co-opted enough of the vote
as they thought they would and they
wanted to end it that's the truth of it
and then there's one guy who came in
there's a couple of us as well but you
know I did a little more a legal
approach um who I guess is a little bit
mouthy and is not going along with
either party who told the truth which
was no both these people are lying but I
or both these parties are lying but I
couldn't go up and do a vlog right it
was Q&A was very rigid very scripted
very you know and I had to do my best to
insert uh the truth of what went on
there and I think over time people will
understand my testimony a lot of people
still don't understand it so that was
the frustrating part of uh came from it
but I've been traveling you know in my
truck when I'm driving I'm in the states
I'm all over the us or at least the
eastern part of the us uh when people
realize who I was who I am because that
does happen from time to time uh they
feel the Americans are funny they feel
like jealous I can't believe Canada did
it you guys beat us to it sort of thing
but uh just overwhelming love and
support here as well uh that's why you
know Carl and the guys had me at Lotus
Eaters uh to sit in with them just all
over the world everybody has been so
warm and loving and appreciative that we
stuck our necks out and we didn't do it
you know for myself we did for all of us
because we got to put an end to clown
world and this was just one element of
clown world that showed the world a how
bad it can get and what I'm trying to
show people is the mechanics of what
goes on behind the scenes and why you
should not trust anything that comes out
of a mouthpiece of a political actor or
people aligned with a political class we
we're going to wrap up in a second but
there's a couple of questions I want to
ask you one trickier than the other I
suppose the real test this is the less
tricky one the real test of whether you
guys made an impact is if we have
another pandemic are we going to go down
the same route and I wonder about that I
don't know what lessons politicians have
learned because I look around
and I think they will be more hesitant
about taking some of the more
authoritarian measures on the one hand
on the other hand they've also applied a
methodology that did actually work which
was you the public and then the public
will demand action and then you do the
action right um that so I suppose the
question is in terms of impact do you
feel that we are in a healthier position
if another pandemic happens or another
public health emergency occurs of some
kind are they going to be less likely to
go down this authoritarian route I don't
know I think it's going to be um
different in every jurisdiction because
what we did is we showed the political
class there is a line in in the sand and
you best not ever cross it ever again
now will everybody listen to it I know a
lot of them will I know a lot of them in
power are fearful of going through the
same thing and being on the wrong side
of it but this is also why I think it's
very important I tell people who are
conservative if you have Progressive
neighborhoods or classically liberal
neighborhood they're eer classically
liberal neighbors talk to them and don't
talk about politics talk about your car
your grass your lawn just start to De
redevelop relationships with people who
you who don't share a political
framework because if not what happens we
turn on each other one of the the
negative things uh that's really
disappointing through all of this you
know I'm sure you had a lot of this Indo
not indoctrination but education on the
Holocaust and what happened in Europe in
the
1930s yeah I know some people who work
at constituency offices work for members
of parliament whatever and the number of
people that were calling into to the
government to rat on their neighbors or
their family members or their C whatever
that has that is not acceptable we
cannot be if you if we are that way as a
society Society will crumble we need to
start building friendships and
relationships with people across the
board uh I told you one of my best
friends is a Brit what he doesn't like
about London
he says everybody's very cold people
won't talk to you uh but I was I was
Charmed to see on on the tube uh a sign
saying a little kindness goes a long way
that's why I try to focus on positive
Framing and focusing on the good in
people even people who we know are
garbage we all know them try to find a
little bit of good try to because if not
we're going to start throwing each other
under the bus and that's what the
political class needs to have another
auth authoritarian lockdown like we had
so if you start shutting out everybody
in your community that divide and
conquer is what they will exploit that's
what they tried to exploit during the uh
the trucker Convoy they tried to get us
all fighting with each other it worked
with some cases didn't work in others
but if we don't allow if we resist that
Temptation then I think we'll be better
off and they won't be able to that's a
really important message and I think one
of the things that people did learn and
the Francis and I know through our
family backgrounds is
no matter how liberal or you know prog
whatever the government's not your
friend that's right they're not your
friend and and they will use you against
each other uh if they want to fulfill
their political Ambitions in that way
the government does not by definition
they can't have your best interests at
heart because they have their own goals
their own objectives they're looking
after a country of different people they
cannot possibly have your interest at
heart by definition and I think we saw
that the question that is more tricky
that that I want to ask you and and I'm
asking you because I wrestle with
it we have the situation particularly
here I don't know how prominent they are
in Canada where we have Extinction
Rebellion protesters uh who block
ambulances from getting to hospitals
they stop people getting to work uh they
block roads and trains and so on and so
forth and uh I disagree with that
because I think the cause that they're
advocating for they completely
misunderstand and the solutions they're
offering are ridiculous Etc but on the
other hand when truckers block a thing
for a cause that I do agree with I have
less hesitation about that right so how
do we square that what is legitimate
protest and when are you taking the pce
as we say in this country yes well I
think firstly in the case of the trucker
protest we were trying to make demands
to remove it what what we were told was
a temporary policy right uh it was not
some ambiguous you know concern some
dark scary thing in the future you know
Scott I'm sure talked to you I haven't
watched the whole interview yet but he
talks about the Adam's law of slow
moving disasters that's where climate
change goes into when I was a kid it was
acid rain was the big thing and we
solved that too and before you were a
kid it was global cooling
by exactly um so I think there's what
we're seeing with the exension Rebellion
stuff that's part of the that's a iCal
tactic right and people argue the
trucker Convoy is a political tactic I
don't know talk to those guys see how
political they are they don't care about
politics they just want to get to work
sort of thing so you know I take your
point but I think a lot of things
sometimes get lost in the Nuance because
we always want to talk about things in
Broad simplistic manners but I think
they're they're quite distinct for that
reason the other thing is when we had
our protest despite what the fake news
will tell you and I have many pictures I
can share with you uh we had every
street because remember we worked with
the city of Ottawa so every street had a
laneway that was open for emergency
vehicles we had a command Cent two
command centers one was security one was
leasing with uh the city of Ottawa in
case there were emergencies ambulance
needed to get through whatever we had a
coordinated team mainly ex police
officers and some ex-military that were
ensuring uh emergency vehicles were not
not uh disrupted so you you know people
see the picture of Wellington Street
that was the main street where all the
trucks were in every lane but all the
other surrounding streets in Ottawa the
trucks were occupying half the street
kind of like the bicycle lanes are doing
now and then the other half was free for
um emergency vehicles and for people if
they needed to drive and I actually Del
leave Ottawa a couple of times and I
have video of me driving back into
Ottawa and it was I was quick as any
other day in Ottawa traffic it was no
different so we weren't s we weren't if
instinction re Rebellion got on a street
and well I mean the cause is an issue
but it would be the the same of them
blocking one lane of roadway on a Major
Street not the entire thing we live in
the UK that is the major Street yeah
that's true that's true you know what I
mean like yeah of course of course and
also you know I wanted just to double
back to a point that you you mentioned
and it's so frustrating for me because
the first organization within I think it
was 13 minutes that smeared us as racist
bigot Nazis white supremacists whatever
was a Jewish organization in Canada tied
to the Liberal Party called Sia they're
the ones who T who released the press
release on behalf of the Prime Minister
to say that we're white supremacists now
I don't know I didn't learn much white
supremacy in the first 13 years of
Hebrew school but me wrong but you know
what I did learn we learned about the
Holocaust all the time and this is where
I get so frustrated with these
organizations because from my
perspective what did I learn in all
those years in school Bingo what I
learned was that was the government in
the 1930s that did that wasn't some
random dude you know and that is so lost
amongst people not just the government
it's the point you made earlier and then
the Soviet Union was same it was the
government getting people brainwashed in
a particular worldview and then getting
Ordinary People to tell on each other to
report each other to the secret police
to hand people in for wrongdoing etc etc
and one of the things that I found
incredible during the whole thing was
like my position on all of this was I'm
against mandates and I'm against mandate
to vaccination right people are free to
have the vaccination people are free to
wear a mask people are free to do
whatever whatever they want right but I
think if you look back the idea that
people shouldn't be forcibly injected
with medical things that they don't wish
to have came out in 1945 for very good
reason very good reason and the fact
that that became like a controversial
thing to say no no no no people came
together in nurburg for a very good
reason and decided we're not going to
let this happen again and the fact that
people were willing to just completely
Overlook that this is the thing is they
flip everything on its head like you say
and you know the you know we always hear
about the white truckers and Ottawa
whatever you know they're all not all
but a very sizable minority maybe even
half of them were from Eastern Europe oh
I bet and you know the last person
standing the last trucker who was
arrested was Chaba vzy and Chaba is from
Romania and he was telling me I took him
to Boston a to to a Bitcoin Freedom
event Bitcoin Freedom
Festival and you know I talked on stage
about the Convoy as we just discussed
right now and I handed the mic over to
him and then he brought the audience
into tears telling him what his family
went through uh under Soviet Union
control that the the government was
always listening to them their children
couldn't hear their conversations
because if their children said the wrong
thing by accident in school then you
were taken away you never maybe never
see your family ever again first chapter
of my book I talk about the talk that
people would have with their kids that's
right and we have we've lost all Concept
in the Western World of TR how truly bad
it is through this Collective
brainwashing in Academia trying to
convince kids I mean I saw it on campus
with my business that they're oh yeah
communism made so bad really why don't
you okay go to China just go go get out
of here we don't need you here leave
like if it's so good sort of thing um
and I know your experience uh you know I
my heart bleeds for I love Latin America
I really do and I see what they've done
to such a beautiful uh country and um I
I hope they come out of it but we need
to be vocal about this and we're not
going to change the world uh and better
it and Free People if we just sit back
and let it happen some of us have to
speak up which is what the freedom
Convoy was about you know the whole
thing that I found so ironic about Co is
that Hitler was actually against
mandated vaccination he thought it was a
bit too far ex he's like no I cannot do
this no this is too far so like even for
anyway but there we go thank you so much
for coming on BJ it's been a wonderful
wonderful chat the final question is
always what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
I well I'm talking about everything so I
there's nothing there's no topic I will
shy away from personally broadly as a
society what do you think needs more
attention than it's getting I guess is
the
question you know we all have our own
frame and you know I've stepped into
this Frame where I'm regularly in
Twitter spaces talking about Freedom
talking about many of the issues we
discussed right here uh from my pers
perspective it's uh this going to get
spicy uh the Islamic uh the islamist
organizations engaged in political
entryism and nobody will talk about it
because they're afraid of the money
that's going to come at them in the form
of lawfare but what we're seeing and you
know it was the the freedom Convoy was
pretty much immune to it but on the
political level we see a very very high
degree of entryism from What's called
the red green Alliance so not a formal
alliance but you know they'll play off
one another which is CCP money and
activists and islamist organizations and
their activists uh engage in political
entryism to co-opt our entire political
system to restrict freedoms and look
what we're seeing is that the source of
it is that who's funding all the
wokeism I don't know but maybe we should
talk more about that and not be so
afraid about what some religious lunatic
might call us I don't really care about
what names people call me anymore well
there you go uh the book is called
honking for Freedom grab it uh wherever
you grab it and head on over to locals
where we continue the conversation
including with manyu of your
questions does BJ think the Liberals can
be defeated at the next elections and
should we trust the conservatives given
their failure to challenge the
government on coid trans nuttiness
[Music]
Etc